nous sommes aujourd'hui au conservatoire
d'orléans dans la salle de l'institut
c'est ici que se déroule tous les deux
ans un grand concours international de
piano
il a été créé par une orléanaise elle
s'appelle françoise thinat et je vous
propose d'aller la retrouver dans le
passé filmé en 1972 au piano ça va de
soi
franz tost inès différents pour vous de
jouer à orléans pourquoi différents non
au contraire d'abord je suis très
heureuse de retrouver ma ville qui est
presque ma ville natale enfin quelque
chose près et puis non au contraire je
vais me trouver dans un chaos
grandissant et heureuse d'y jouer dans
mes amis jean je connais mieux peut-être
que l étranger par exemple
bonjour françois stinat bonjour ça vous
fait quoi de revoir cette image une
élégance de l'époque les boucles
d'oreilles le chinon tout tremblement
maintenant on n'oserait plus avant tout
à fait me mets quoi c'est venu comment
la musique classique et le piano tout
particulier lorsque ma mère était
professeur de piano qu'on vivait là
dedans c'était une ambiance je sais pas
si maintenant il ya il ya sûrement
encore des familles où on fait de la
musique le dimanche qu'on fait on était
dans une famille qu'on appelle une
famille de musiciens de gens qui font ça
non pas professionnellement mais comme
amateur on va faire un autre bond dans
le temps françoise thinat nous sommes
cette fois ci en 1984 vous êtes dans nos
studios à fr3 vous participez à
l'émission régional l'embarras du choix
vous êtes en compagnie d'henri masse et
grâce à henry mais on va en savoir un
tout petit peu plus sur vous regardez
vous êtes orléanaise vous avez un nom
célèbre que l'on évoque à peine mais
vous vous êtes fait comme disait sacha
après non après avoir eu un non alors
vous êtes professeur au conservatoire
récemment depuis le mois de janvier
j'étais professeur pendant sept ans à
toulouse alors france lost in à henri
masse c'est bien mystérieux vous avez un
nom célèbre mais il n'a pas voulu nous
dire alors vous êtes la fille la fille
de monsieur le maire le se renie tina
qui est d'ailleurs il m'aura si
brutalement c'était un très gros remous
dans riant il ya eu quand même autour de
sa mort comment dire une espèce de deux
symphonies de gens qu'il aimait beaucoup
j'ai toujours été reconnaissante à tous
ces gens qu'ils ont veillé pendant cinq
jours à la mairie c'était quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire comme vous savez
qu'il ya encore des gens qui me parlent
de mon père c'est encore voilà il a
laissé un souvenir d'un homme
d'allemagne est ce qu'on appelait
autrefois ce que molière ap un honnête
homme est d'ailleurs très tournée vers
la musique
on va faire un autre bond dans le temps
nous sommes cette fois ci en 1993
vous êtes de retour à la télévision
régionale vous êtes l'invité du journal
et vous venez parler de quelque chose
qui vous tient particulièrement à coeur
de quoi s'agit-il
corinne de rosa qui présente le journal
ce jour là nous dit tout un grand
concours international de piano à
orléans ce n'est plus un rêve ce sera
une réalité du 28 février au 6 mars
grâce à vous françoise thinat bonsoir
alors il y a déjà des concours
prestigieux oui j'en ai demandé pourquoi
de plus qu'est ce qu'il rate plus lire
il a beaucoup de choses qui sont tout à
fait exceptionnels c'est ce qui
intéresse beaucoup par exemple les
candidats qui ont dépassé la trentaine
et qui retrouve un deuxième souffle au
travail et un répertoire puisqu'il est
sur le xxème siècle ça m'amuse parce
cette interview parce que j'ai dit des
choses que je pourrais dire encore
maintenant c'est à dire effectivement
l'ouverture à des gens qui ont dépassé
la trentaine et qui se penche vers ce
répertoire qui est un répertoire très
très lourd l'organisatrice a voulu
mettre la barre très haut pour les
candidats un cv et les recommandations
de personnalité musique
éminente pour les huit membres du jury
donc de chef d'orchestre
la connaissance de toutes les partitions
proposés et puis c'est une occasion
unique de faire le tour du monde
comment ça marche concrètement ils ont
des espèces des preuves de saute-mouton
a passé exactement comme les vrais
encore international faudrait
signalement donné un vrai aussi mais je
veux dire on passe par le premier round
de diamant en 3d - on et puis la finale
à chaque fois ça se rétrécit ya plus de
quinze personnes et plus que cette
personne et voilà
c'est un concours qui a débuté il ya
quelques jours en fait et vous françoise
thinat où en est votre carrière
aujourd'hui en 2014
ensuite je pense ici à l'école normale
j'ai 22 élèves professionnels très lourd
ma carrière je joue du piano voix là
encore bien sûr je joue bien sûr je
continue on peut pas s'en passer
ce qui est drôle tel est justement on va
se quitter comme ça merci françoise
thinat de retrouver la mémoire en notre
compagnie et on va vous revoir à l'image
vous êtes au piano bien sûr et vous
interpréter un morceau de debussy et
puis sinon partys